Let's just have a look for a minute at the let clause,
which is way of doing a local abbreviation or a local definition.
Say you have you a relatively complex computation that you're going to
include in one of your constraints, and you're going to use it more than once.
Now, you could type it out more than once, but that's extra effort and
you might make a mistake. So instead, you could use a let clause to
introduce a new identifier that has the value of that expression, and
then use that identifier in a subsequent constraint. So for example,
if our income is expressed in terms of the sum of our of our salaries for
all of our jobs, okay, we could use a let clause which says exactly that.
We could introduce a new variable, or
identifier called income and then we could have expression, in this case is
an if then else expression that says if someone is unemployed then their income
is less than 100 else their income is greater then or equal to 100. It's just as
if we've typed in the long expression in both the places where we used to.